okay uh good evening everyone and
welcome to this evening's meeting of the
executive um if I start with the uh item
one which is attendances I'm noting
apologies from councelor Kath Hines I
don't think anyone
else I've not certainly not had any
apologies submitted I can see everyone
in the room around me so that's great so
we move on to item two Declarations of
Interest I've received none in advance
of the meeting anyone have any
Declarations of Interest
no thank you in that case we'll move on
to item three which is questions from
the public I believe we have two
questions from Mr boy this evening um I
think they relate to the same paper so I
don't know if Emma you want to read them
both out at the same time and then we'll
get the responses at the same time so
over to you thank you thank you chair um
they do relate to um two different
reports so I'll read the first question
which is uh in reference to the treasury
management report please could the
executive member for finance give some
information as to why the following two
funds have been preferred for
significant additional deposits SL
investment namely Invesco aim and legal
and
general H thank you uh leader um I'm
really sorry but the the the response to
this question has green ink over it and
I've just tried to lightly zooming in on
a phone it's like playing Havoc with my
eyes here so I do apologize I will read
um the detailed response here the
council invests monies which are
available for example grants received in
advanc of spend requirement um of from
the balances and reserves which it holds
in making any investment the first
priority is to ensure an appropriate
level of security and liquidity of
council funds is maintained and then to
achieve a return Revenue
return these Investments are made in
accordance with the treasury management
invest M strategy approved by Council in
February each year the strategy provides
a framework of limits and criteria which
in conjunction with regular updates of
credit ratings and independent
counterparty advice allows the council's
in-house treasury management team to
invest funds appropriately the
Investments referenced in the question
have been placed in accordance with the
strategy and are within the approved
limits for that Investment Group they
are instant access short term
investments placed to provide a return
to the council while maintaining the
liquidity requirements of the council's
cash flow thank
you thank you very much Council Harding
and if we move on to question two
then question two relates to the
corporate plan uh section 2.3 in respect
of electric vehicle charging
infrastructure having noted several
times daytime that the charging points
at sail water park were not being used
by by any Vehicles could the appropriate
executive member advise the terms on
which the council receives Financial
renumeration from usage of EV charging
throughout the Bor and the level of
remuneration that's been received in
each of the last three months in
particular from the multiple
installation at the water
park thank you um councelor
Williams thank you chair in light of the
technical nature of the question I
probably def to riched if that's all
right thank you
I think if we can provide a written
response after the
meeting thank you I'm happy with that so
that's uh is that item if we move on now
to item four which is Matters from the
council or overview and scrutiny
committees and uh councelor Acton I
believe you got a report on access to
council services so over to
you yes thank you leader um following a
request from office offers for
information of
services who answer calls um the
scrutiny committee discovered that this
information is not recorded apart from
calls to the council's contact
center therefore the scrutiny committee
recommend the executive take action to
address the Gap in service and provide
Assurance to the committee and and
residents that all services are
contactable contactable yeah that's a
word um by the public with upto-date
numbers on departmental
websites so we're asking the executive
to consider seven
recommendations which are set out in the
report and I won't read those out um the
seventh of those
recommendations is that a report on the
steps taken by the executive to address
these issues be provided to the scrutiny
committee that our meeting on the 13th
of March next year so um you know we're
hoping to get a a response back I think
it is an important issue leader and I
hope that you consider it um you know
thoroughly thank you very much councilor
Aton you're quite right it is a very
important uh issue the way that our
residents can get in touch with us and
our Council Services um I knowe the
report says the 13th of March 2023 in it
which is why you said next year which
was my only question on it so we will uh
we will endeavor to get feedback to you
for that uh scrutiny meeting but thank
you very much for putting that report
together we will take it away digest it
and come back to you at that scrutiny
meeting um councelor but anything you'd
like to uh say
just a short one chair to do with the
task and finish group meeting we had
last Thursday 7th December and we had a
presentation Blue Sky which is a uh
giving us uh in feedback from service
users significant flare within the
voluntary sector for regards mental
health issues and uh other issues that
young and old people have loneliness
various things so it was an interesting
presentation but um we forward that to
the main scrutiny committee and give you
some more information your course thank
you thank you very much Council but
again that sounds like a very important
piece of work in an area that we we
certainly need to give uh some Focus to
so thank you for that okay if we move on
to item five which is the minutes from
the meeting that was held on the 15th of
November um not not the most recent one
on the 27th are people happy to approve
the minutes from the 15th of
November oh yes so councelor Evans I may
have missed this but I thought I had
asked for some information on the 12
million which is mentioned in this
report on
page 31 I think um and that's not
minuted or I can't see
it that is a good question that is the
two weeks ago the exec that we had there
so this is from the 15th and as it
happens I know that we're going to get
you that information because I did ask
graem about that earlier today so I
think we're we will be providing you
that information I did Chase it up for
you but thank you okay moving on we go
to um item six which is indeed the
treasury management annual performance
report the midyear um report here so
I'll pass over to councilor Harding uh
thank you leader the recommendations are
that this report the the report um the
accounts and audit committee and the
executive be requested to note the
treasury management activities
undertaken in the first half of
2324 the report gives members a summary
of the treasury management activities
undertaken for the first half of
2324 and just to say about the report
and for reference sigfa has defined
treasury management as the management of
the local authorities borrowing
Investments and cash flows its banking
money market and Capital Market
transactions and the effective control
of the risks associated with those
activities so this is one of three
reports the strategy will be tabled in
February the report shows the level of
debt level of investment and provides an
update on credential indicators no
credential indicators have been breached
uh there's a level of detail contained
within the report which as I say is for
noting just to um mention as well though
I think as I said with the draft budget
report how important it is for
councilors to feel confident confident
and competent to ask questions on
subject matters that can sometimes feel
Technical and a little um scary there
will be some training available in
January for all members in relation to
credential indicators and treasury
management which I think will be quite
timely really because it comes ahead of
the report to be tabled in February so
as I've said really the report is for
noting by the executive thank you
leader thank you very much are there any
questions or comments from members of
the
executive any wider questions councilor
but thank you ch um I've just got three
questions here uh one is to do with the
external debt to finance in your
borrowings I know that the uh the debt
is it seems to have been pushed sort of
further along down the line to certain
extent it's current external dat 36
million uh and
then in the following years it ends up
then 20 25 26 to 717 million um I know
that's seems to have been pushed along
um I'm just wondering is that the the
best way to be doing that uh you know
creating a problem further down the line
the other one is there's 18 loans from P
wlb public work loans loans board and it
says how much that money is actually at
the 9% rate uh at the higher level
uh I think I'll just leave it at that
because there'll probably be some other
questions other people so thank you
councel but um do did you want to
reference which page your first question
was on just so I can gra if you got it
it's okay gr's got it
so I think just on the phas in of
borrowing so I think what we're mindful
doing is just reflecting where the
capital program and the asset strategy
projections are going and that's what
we're doing there so it's just it's just
simply a reflection of when our planned
spend and particularly that spend that's
financed by borrowing is going to take
place
um and that's just a reflection of
delivery of projects so I don't think
there's anything else to say there I
think in terms of
the the position on our debt costs if I
can just find the table
um which indicates what
our average interest rates are on our
debt of at the end of September we're
looking at an average rate there of
2.55% I think the majority of our debt
is therefore the low rates of Interest
as opposed to high given where the
average rate is but I can confirm the
exact number to you but it will be a
small proportion of our over okay yes
said said it up to 9% so I'll just
whether how much of that was at that
higher level that's it will be low but
I'll confirm that okay thank
you thank you and councelor
Evans similar on on the table on page 31
um couple couple of questions um
operational boundary for external debt
investment strategy approved limit 375
million thought we'd authorize up to
half a million half a billion 500
million I might be wrong there we might
have brought it down last year and I
must might missed it but that's where I
thought that was
um a and could you explain uh the under
borrowed what that what does that
actually mean um is that a gearing thing
what what does that in reality
mean thanks gr I'll just take them in
order I think the 375 reference to the
the investment
strategy um within our credential
indicators that reflects our budgeted
need in 234 so it don't reflect what's
already gone so you're right that the
overall value of the asset investment
fund is still 500 but the fact that some
of that borrowings already been
undertaken it might been undertaken in
223 which is why that figure's not
showing
500 um the question in terms of under
borrowed is an interesting one
um in
the if I just set it out that each each
time the authority has a requirement to
borrow and that is purely in respect of
any
capital capital expenditure or any
investment through the asset
strategy if at that point that we incur
the expenditure we don't borrow that
then becomes badged as under borrowed
so we will look to take that borrowing
up at a point in time if that's
necessary and our cash flow dictates
that we need to do that but a a lot of
the activity that comes through the
asset strategy is relatively shortterm
Investments so in some cases we can live
with that under borrowing position for a
period of 12 24 months when when the
investment might get
repaid so we we try to balance that the
number is quite a large number I think
I think it's fair to say that a lot of
authorities are carrying large numbers
of under borrowing figures because
obviously we've got the exposure to what
are relatively higher interest rates at
the moment
so we are trying to in buy our time when
we actually have to go out to borrow
again and that's part of the
contributing thing as to why we're under
borrowed but we need to manage that the
borrowing requirement is still there if
we need to take it um but at the moment
the figure is as it is is quite high on
borrowed
figure okay thank you very much so um
thanks as ever to our uh our highly
skilled treasury management team who
work very hard with our money and look
after it very well for us so thank you
very much for that and this is for
noting everyone happy to
note BR right we'll move on to item
seven then which is the corporate Plan
update which you will see is um is is
split in into a service update that
covers our three corporate priorities
which are reducing Health inequalities
supporting people out of poverty and
addressing our climate crisis there's
also a um rag rating table of other
things that um that that go beyond those
corporate priorities there as well I
think it's a good story to tell here um
we've seen over the years some
progression with our School Street
schemes we've seen an improvement in the
number of affordable housing completions
we've got a very good story to tell on
our recycling rates and also our Library
borrow borrowing remains very healthy so
some some good things to pick out there
um clearly as we look ahead we'll be
looking to refresh our plan over the
next few months and work with partners
and engage with other people as we as we
look at what's relevant for Trafford as
we head into 2024 and we hope to have
that final plan some point in the summer
um but with that I wonder if there are
any questions or comments from members
of the executive uh councilor
Williams and thank you chair just
briefly I wanted to touch on a couple of
items in the report um I'm really
pleased to speak to section 2.3 of the
report addressing our climate crisis in
particular I'm delighted that the
council has now recruited to our new
head of climate change and
sustainability post and I'd like to take
this opportunity to thank colleagues and
the administration for their support in
securing additional resource to enhance
to enhance the council's capacity to
engage in the important work of
responding to the climate crisis the
report also highlights the establishment
of B climes in sail and flion with
further locations planned in Stratford I
should also add that B clim has also
been delivered at Would S and I'd like
to take this opportunity to both
congratulate and thank officers and my
colleagues councelor W Stanley and
councelor matland for all of their
efforts to secure that provision thank
you
chair thank you quite right I think
something that we've established as a
council is when we put the resource in
it does help deliver our on our
priorities so we we're delighted to have
that new resource in place there and
likewise like to see the bike liers and
I hope there's an opportunity given I've
now got a cycle puncture to uh to get
that fixed at one of the libraries
because I don't know how to do that
myself um councilor Patel you indicated
thank you welcome this report I think
it's a very open and transparent report
about the work that we do which is um
you know very Broad and wide ranging the
good and the bad where we could improve
where we've done well um I'm pleased to
see the following the conclusion of the
poverty truth commission we've adopted
their four recommendations and that
piece of work is embedded in the
decision making process as we move
forward um Longford Park obviously um
very pleased we secured the funding but
particular aspect of that the deuling of
the um Brook through there is actually a
very interesting piece of work for us in
Trafford um a new piece of work for us
that could have um lessons to be learned
on in other green spaces um I'm very
pleased we've um put together a
developer hub for Trafford for people
wanted to build in Trafford as a
One-Stop point of information for them
um on the employment rate in Trafford um
uh which is marked in red we are uh
renewing currently our um Trafford
education Enterprise and skills action
plan so that's a body we work with GM
partners and local Partners um postco
Trafford um has been quite impacted by
the lot of a a large chunk of over 50s
in the workforce who decided to take the
opportunity to um withdraw from the
labor market so we're looking to
actively encourage those very skilled
and experienced people um back into the
work for us thank
you thank you councilor Patel yes I mean
the um the work around Longford park it
will be very interesting and probably a
case study for our integrated Water
Management plan at a GM level as well um
councelor
Thompson thank you I welcome this report
it just shows how busy we are and and um
all the initi iives that we're
undertaking and we are really ambitious
Council I just wanted to add that maybe
there should be uh an extra part under
other highlight highlights to recognize
that parks and green spaces were awarded
11 green flags this this summer and
that's under challenging conditions and
a very small budget for perhaps and GD
spaces but I think that should be
highlighted and thanks to the
friends par groups who do all the work
for
us thank you councelor Thompson I think
you've done a very good job in
highlighting that achievement there and
then and and clearly that's thanks to
council officers our one Trafford
officers and of course the friends of
parks groups as well who have been
working incredibly hard for many many
years so that now to keep that standard
up it's something we're very proud of in
Trafford um councelor ad said did you
indicate just uh briefly yeah
of good things have been said already so
I just want to comment uh one particular
point on page 44 about the tree planting
with city of trees I think that's quite
tremendous no pun intended there by the
way in case you thought it was it really
it it wasn't it wasn't honestly but yeah
uh for those who not know we've been
working closely with City trees over the
last few years and now crossr to
Manchester that they've actually got
officers based in each local auth yeah
in each of the 10 local authorities now
so they're actually working with
Community groups and organizations to
actually help so they can work with
those get schemes off the ground they
can help put bids in I think it's really
a great initiative and with with those
sort of initiatives going forward I
think we can look forward to a lot more
uh of our tree planting scheme anded
obviously with the proposal that I set
out in the report for Woodland creation
and it's been agreed for the current
planting see well for the planting
season up post Christmas I think that's
really great news I there so much we
it's not just obviously it's obviously
all it takes all the right boxes
Environmental Green obviously everything
that we're doing I those sort of
projects are fantastic and I think we
need to make more of those as well thank
you absolutely and and and it is a
budget that we looked after as well and
and made sure we kept so it's incredibly
important what city of trees do does and
indeed forms part of the Northern Forest
as well which is again something that's
quite an interesting concept and
something necessary um councilor slate
thank you leader um I just like to point
out in the report around how we've been
working really hard on our health
inequalities and the work that we've
done uh over the last 12 months around
smoking and smoking testation has been
really U really positive and um our
needs assessment are showing quite a few
changes around people who smoke and
obviously the use of Vapes for people
who smoke as opposed to Vapes and young
people and and I was really proud that
at full Council that we took the um the
motion around um young people and vaping
I think that it was really important
that that is that is something that we
tackle uh this year head on I think the
the work that we're doing around oral
health is really important I think that
you know our Public Health Team we
working really closely um with with um
our preschool children and providing
um teeth cleaning um uh support and
stuff like that and and and the stuff
that we're doing around alcohol and
substance misuses you know we are doing
a very very lot of work and we are
focusing on those communities where um
alcohol and substance misuse is been um
you know is prevalent but you know the
needs assessment is showing us that
we've got you know a lot lot further to
go and the rest of the work that's going
to commence in uh 2024 is something that
it's going to be exciting again for us
to be able to support and challenge um
and you know make our make our residents
a lot healthier so really good really
good work the report is excellent the
stuff that we're doing in in the green
spaces really important for People's
Health so that they can walk safely and
all those kind of things so brilliant
brilliant report and I'm so happy to
support it and thank you leader thank
you and of course the investment and
support we do around health and public
health does help keep keep people
healthier which again does have benefits
long term for us as a bough as well
councelor Carter um thank you leader I'd
just like to congratulate all our
children young people um we can see from
this report that even at the very
earliest stage our traffic children have
got a good level um of
development um so they're getting a
great start in
Trafford um and that continues up into
you know we know we get great
educational results another thing a bit
like rose that's not included here is
the amount of schools that we've got
that are good and out understanding and
we really need to recognize that as an
authority um I've got a question that um
when we've marked down and read the
percentage take up of funded child care
for two year olds um and I'm not quite
sure why that's read so maybe we'd like
to relook at that because actually if
we're second in the Northwest and eighth
nationally it's not a it's not an area
for concern as far as I can see but just
well done to everybody working in the
sector to keep our young children at the
top of their
agenda thank you councilor Carter and as
I said at the start of the Year giving
children and young people the best start
in life is something that's Central to
what we want to do and I'm sure that
will feed into our refresh of the
corporate plan plan in coming months are
there any oh councelor
right thank you I thought I'd join the
party um just I won't repeat anything
anyone else has said the the only one
thing another thing that I think could
be in the report or mention potentially
in the other items is the successful bid
for the leveling up fund for part his
Leisure Center by Council officers which
is obviously a fantastic um thing which
will mean the um complete Redevelopment
of par and leure center and the impact
that will have on the health and
well-being of residents across traffic
thank you thank you and that goes back
to an original point that councilor
Williams was saying when you put the
resource in it does help deliver so
putting that extra resource into our
Sport and Leisure was one of the key
contributors as toward securing that
leveling up bid so we had quite right to
to raise that well thank you everyone
are there any questions from the if
members right councelor Evans first of
all thank you uh I'll just pick on on
three items uh page 53 uh improve the
energ epcs um it is p really not moved
the dial hardly in five years um I would
have thought with connections with
registered providers and also with
having National residential an laws
Association actually based in sale we
might be in a strong position to
influence that and that
would uh travel into the other parts of
the corporate planning that it would
help with poverty Etc and fuel um
poverty um what are we doing about that
that is terribly bad really and we could
really help people quickly um with that
one um CO2 emissions across the B again
not moved at all on that dial not not
shifted one one iota and finally um I'm
actually less concerned about those two
although they are very important but
towards the back end I think it's page
is it 62 or 82 62 the top one proportion
of experienced care experienced people
that has just got crashed I would have
thought that' be some getting a care
lever to have a social worker I'd have
thought would have be relatively easy to
solve um and what are we doing about
that to to get ahead of that thank you
thank you so the first two I will defer
to councelor Williams first first of all
and then possibly to
Richard thank you chairman I think
councelor you're correct to um highlight
the issue that we have in terms of
improving performance around energy
performance of our properties um
councilor Patel said earlier that you
know it is a bit of a mixed picture it's
an honest report and it recognizes that
we've had some successes but there are
also some challenges and I think that
improving the energy performance of our
residential units is a real challenge
because it's not directly within
Trafford council's gift um what you may
be aware of I'm not sure of any of your
residents are impacted but the council
has started sending out its letters um
for the eall Improvement service so
that's if you qualify residents um on
specific um support from the Department
of working pensions can apply for
funding to have energy performance
Improvement measures installed at their
property so those letters have started
going out this week um but that's just
part of part of the um Journey that
we're on in terms of improving the
energy performance properties in terms
of the registered providers you're right
again to highlight them um I think we
have better working relationships with
some RPS than we do with others um I've
met with ell Valley they've done some
fantastic work in s West in terms of
trying to improve the energy performance
of their properties but again we're
nowhere near the end of that process so
thank you for your question I think
you're right um to highlight the issues
that we have um with the energy
performance of our of our
units I'm not sure Richard if there's
something you want to
come you can come back briefly all night
yes would you send me a copy of what
you're sending out to the residents to
to offer what's being offered and also
you can perhaps get our teams
out um Cel Patel Just on that point um
the the first round of of funding from
government to GM uh to registered
housing providers um has been allocated
and spent um lnq didn't apply for that
and if they had
there wouldn't have been enough money in
that first round so you know there is a
second round I believe the the letters
that have gone out to Residents I've
picked up on social media and from
inquiries from my colleagues that there
is a lot of skepticism about whether
it's a scam or not and it's totally
legitimate so I think sort of consumer
surveys show a great deal of mistrust
around people selling Energy Efficiency
stuff windows and you know it's got a
bad reputation hasn't it so perhaps
there's a piece of work for us all to do
to reassure res that is a legitimate
offer and if they qualify it's it's
something absolutely worth taking
it yeah thanks for that Council Patel I
know there is a big push from the
combined Authority level around
retrofitting both with social landlords
and also private um private uh
properties as well and with the
Trailblazer um coming into play that
will form a big part of what we want to
do for the greatest Manchester level um
in terms of the carbon dioxide Richard
can I defer to you on that
one you can I was whil you were asking
the question I was looking for the EPC
Target so what was the he just repeat
the the question or where it is in the
report the EPC tet was 42.7% I've got
that what's the co the co CO2 well it
started in at four
1496 at 2122 is 1442 so it had gone back
down by not much um our Target is 1271
we seem so far away from that
um for quite a lot of effort are we
putting the effort in the right place I
suppose is Sneak another question
in uh I mean I think it is it is
difficult to move the dial again out the
amount of the ability of us to influence
this target directly is quite uh limited
because we are relying on what else is
happening in the economy we relying on
vehicle movements relying on Energy
Efficiency properties going back to the
EP
question so I think we are pushing where
we can but I think you know we we are
operating with for a Target here that is
not entirely within our
gift what I would say is that we have
been embracing the public sector
decarbonization schemes so a lot of our
public buildings including this one here
have been through measures so in the
town hall we've got the LED lighting
program which is clearly making an
impact and in the Leisure centers as
well a lot of work is um is going in as
we invest in those leure centers to
reduce emissions there it will be the
same with other public um sector
buildings um and I think there is an
appetite in the private c as well
clearly that's outside of our gift but
we know from you know key players in in
Trafford you know people are Keen to
reduce the carbon footprint and and work
in Partnership um where necessary to to
do that from a burough and GM
perspective okay so oh yes and we must
go now to the care lever question as
well so Jill so just in terms of that
question I would absolutely agree it
it's absolutely vital we stay in touch
with our care experiencing people as
you'll see from the comments and the
narrative that that H we've set ourself
a stretch Target which is different from
the national Target and that stretch
Target is that we are in touch with our
care experience young people at a
minimum of eight weeks not 12 weeks
which is the national Target if we
measured ourselves against the national
Target the percentage would be 92% of
all of our care experienced young people
we would be in touch with against our
stretch Target it's
76.6% which is a significant increase
from the 38% in 1920 so couldn't agree
more it's absolutely vital and we also
measure against the quality of that in
touch whether it's by phone call whether
it's by text or whether it's face Toof
face um contact and visit thank
you thank you very much so uh councelor
Enis
thank you very much leader um there's
lots lots to welcome in this uh
especially the steps forward that's
another point for councelor aded steps
forward made on the brinwood Move
initiative um and the many many other
things that are exciting happening at
brinwood Community Center at the minute
we've got successful jobs Club up and
running their mental health
practitioners coming in the new year and
lots of other initiatives aimed at
tackling the cost of living as well I do
have a couple of questions Council
Slater I think first mentioned oral
health and I think it's worth mentioning
that broomwood hasn't had full-time NHS
dentist on the estate for some time now
uh and that is clearly having an impact
to hear that all the time in my emails
so I'd urge the council to work with the
school and with the third sector there
to make sure that we don't have a
Dentistry uh not spot and uh in terms of
supporting people out of poverty as well
the the end of the household support
fund potential end of the household
support fund is is very Bleak news uh
for the council's ability to support
vulnerable households it beggers belief
really uh that the government thinks now
is the time uh for that support to end
so I'd like to ask how the council will
try try being the operative word
accepting that it's a significant uh
void but try to build the uh the void
and step in with with other initiatives
to support people with the cost of
within crisis which has anything
boated okay um thank you for both
questions um if I go to you council
state first of all thank you for the
comments Council if we can speak about
it separately if you can give me some
more detail I'm quite happy to go and
speak to NHS colleagues to find out what
we can do and but Public Health are
working with our own five so if there's
anything we can do around that as well
um we'll make sure that we get people
in and on the household support fund
before I go to James and possibly Rose
as well it is clearly something that
we're concerned about seeing that news
we hope that money comes through but um
it's going to involve a lot of
partnership work but even with that
you know we do fear for for what the
impact of that is but Council right do
you want to add
more yeah all just just just to
reiterate what he said there later and
what councelor en said which is I found
found it absolutely astonishing that the
government have have thought this is a
good time to get rid of this potential
to get rid of this
funding given how well how well it's
been taken across the whole political
divide and how vital all the funding has
been since covid times they think as we
are going into another winter cost
living crisis this is the correct time
to do it we will do whatever we can with
Partners to try and get some of that
funding uh back from whatever we can but
it's going to be very difficult for us
to do so and I would obviously urge
other colleagues from the conservatives
here tonight to spe to see what they can
do to their government to get the
household support fund um back in action
from April of next year because it is
vitally important to us thank you thank
you councelor right uh councelor Paul
did you indicate ear
yes yeah thank you chair uh this is
quite an in-depth report and many things
to be welcomed in here uh my question is
relating to housing so page 43 uh it
says the housing options service
Trafford host and housing strategy and
growth teams Patrol uh the burrow
looking for rough sleepers to help and
advice this is a fantastic thing that
they're doing but does host or housing
strategy assess those people who have
received house placement through Council
but their circumstances have changed or
might have changed like some might be
earning more or might have children who
have grown up and left home and thus may
not be in need of the big house which
they were originally alloted so does
council or TT hedge take up any kind of
such assessment of change circumstances
so that some other needy people can be
offer offered that house or dwelling
thank you thank you councelor Paul
councelor
wght uh thank you leader yeah just in
relation to that so the there there is a
matching service that goes on between
obviously people who may need to
downsize and who who people who may need
to um to upsize um it to to be perfectly
honest there's very few and far between
um because uh there are not a huge
amount of people who want to move
regardless of how big their property is
because they've lived there for so many
years the option is there there are
couple of various different websites
that are not necessar not run by the
council but but run within GM and by um
lmq as well um it does happen
particularly as the bedroom tax over the
last 10 years is sort of me that people
have been forced to move on uh should we
say um into smaller
properties we can try and get you some
figures on on what's happened in the Bor
um over the last few years help thank
you but I would I would hesitate to say
that it's probably a fairly minimal
figure to be honest because the
availability of smaller properties in
particular um that have been coming
through for social rent has been has
been so small thank you thank you
okay thank you and counselor Enis you
indicated again yeah sorry I just wanted
to come back in on um the sorry Council
won uh the EPC certificates just really
quickly um following on from what
council Patel said earlier I just make
the point that many people who live who
who are impacted these properties who
may need to make an application uh are
quite can be harder to reach so the
letter is very he very good uh but
what's being done to reach people who
who may be a little bit harder to reach
and might need support with
applications or are digitally
isolated thank you councelor this
councelor
Williams maybe the Council of to ISM
stally responds to this I must have I
was just going to share with you counc
you know with a different hat on my day
job is as a housing officer in sford and
one of the things that I do is go door
too trying to engage our residents um to
encourage them to take up the
opportunity to um have Improvement
measures installed at their properties
I'll be honest with you is the challenge
you know Tom rightly indicated that a
lot of people feel a bit skeptical about
these schemes but there's also residents
who just don't want to have to put up
with the disturbance to their day-to-day
life of operatives going into their
property sometimes for weeks on end so I
think it is a challenge but um I think
we're only going to make progress on
this if we fight on multiple funds so
that's why the work with registered
providers is so important I suppose is
what I would say um and one of the
things that we were very conscious of
when drafting the Eco for letter was
that it should be
and you know
accessible um not too complicated
English language so that residents
perhaps who haven't got the literacy
levels so those of us gathered here
today um can understand the gist of what
we're trying to encourage they engage
with uh thank you
chair thank you uh councilor Patel sorry
just to say I've been door knocked by
the company um that are carrying out
these workers in Trafford and I've seen
them set out a stall in erston town
center and S Town Center although you
might avoid them because they look a bit
like charity chuggers but I think there
is a a piece of work to do around
reassuring people that it's a legitimate
offer that that they should um
consider thank you and then finally
councelor
Welton thank you uh everyone's stealing
our agenda so I'm very very happy with
that I have to say um yeah just a
comment on on on the the the the chugger
of those of those sellers then you know
maybe offering them spaces in our
libraries or something like that
somewhere that's just got a little bit
more you know just feels a little bit
more serious and safe um might be a um
might be an option just came to mind um
then um I just wanted to add some one
thing that isn't mentioned in this
report and has just come into our
inboxes recently is is that the the
progress towards some pilots on 20 M
hour zones is um in in in three areas of
Trafford is is very is very welcome um
obviously subject to the the
consultation that's going on at at the
moment so hopefully that will help
progress some of these um these
targets uh just on the epcs as we're all
very concerned about that this evening
I'm wondering given you know we are we
sounds like we're under borrowed at the
moment there are a lot of people who
can't access um the uh the um sort of
national funding currently um because of
you know because they earn more than
that limit is there any role in for for
the council in terms of creating a
package of micro financing that people
can that can can access um to be able to
you know afford measures for the better
afford measures for their for their
houses and maybe the council could make
some money out of that in the future or
potentially a pilot role you know um an
opportunity to create a pilot where we
we create a you know an area of Trafford
a small maybe a ward maybe a few streets
where we can really go for
decarbonization help fund decar
decarbonization of of the housing stock
so we can learn how it works in those
you know those few streets um and then
roll that pilot out o over a wider area
that would would seem like a really um a
good good option um just wondering what
you think about that um and finally you
know can we help um bring in the private
sector or or community the community
sector to help with some of our
decarbonization projects we're obviously
talking about the public sector
decarbonization program but we've got
this greater Manchester Community
Renewables who are putting solar panels
on Wellington School um with no capital
outlay from the school at all and
they're interested in working with other
schools around the burough if we could
if if schools can lease their roof space
to them um you know is there a role can
can can we help um those kind of
organizations get involved um quicker um
you know so things happen faster than
than things are happening at the moment
on you know given some of these
indicators are shifting slower than we'd
like thank
you thank you I think on your final
point that that there is scope to
explore what we can do more with
Community schemes Community groups and
that's why we've got additional capacity
that we're investing in the the service
now to look at what the art of the
possible would be in terms of how we
partner up with others in terms of the
uh before I pass over to council William
um examples of um decarbonized
properties I mean we're fortunately
enough to be getting quite a few new
builds now that have got um some you
know some good energy saving uh examples
within them which we can we could use
and hopefully imitate across uh wider
areas in terms of the lending element I
was looking over to Graham just to see
how is uh I was looking at that but
Richard is indicated so I'll bring
Richard in
first thank you leader and thank you
counc wel for the questions just a
couple of comments suppose um that
community that area focused approach uh
that you articulated there is
essentially what local authorities uh
used to do so we had a housing renewal
uh scheme in Old Trafford which run for
10 years took an area based approach to
improve properties including addressing
Energy Efficiency um we simply don't
have the level of funding to be able to
do that type of scheme anymore although
if you go around Old Trafford you can
see how successful um it was on the on
the loans that is something that we can
explore there is a risk that comes with
that inevitably and I've have no doubt
that you'll recall that during the uh
coalition government 2010 to 2015 there
was an approach there around the
approach around Energy Efficiency works
at that point was dependent on
householders taking out loans which were
then secured against the property for
Energy Efficiency works the takeup of
that scheme was incredibly low um
because people didn't want to take that
risk and secure that loan against
against the prop property so there are
there are real challenges with
delivering Energy Efficiency schemes
which isn't to say that we shouldn't
push it and we absolutely do we really
push it from with the ecoar and other
schemes as councilor Williams said
people getting people to take up those
offers even when you are offering to do
works for free is incredibly uh
difficult and doing it when people have
to pay is is uh is more even more
difficult and often that the payback
those people who really need it uh in
terms of financially are often those who
are least able to afford the cost of
doing um uh the
works thank you councilor
Williams thank you chairman thank you
councilor welon for your question I
appreciate it um I think everything
Richard said there is correct and I
completely reiterate it I think for me
part of the challeng is the scale of the
problem in Trafford so the average
energy performance certificate for a
residential unit in Trafford is band d
as I understand it um you know that's
not where we want to be but it's just a
reality that comes with the age of our
housing stock and I think you know it
wouldn't be responsible of me tonight to
sort of try and um on the cuff come up
with a financial package from traffic
Council especially given the financial
position we find ourselves in but I
think I suspect that your sympathy lies
with mine and what I would like to see
is the government come up with a
meaningful offer for people who perhaps
um aren't on a means tested benefit but
don't have the finances themselves um to
uh resource um energy Improvement
measures to their property I think
really this needs to be led by central
government in terms of your question
around um supporting schools that wish
to have um solar installed or other
energy performance measures installed
outside of the public set
decarbonization scheme that is a body of
work that the estate's team are
undertaking um alongside the principal
officer of climate change and
sustainability and then just reflecting
on your comments about supporting the
private sector I think you're right to
raise that because you know Trafford is
unique really in terms of local
authorities um in the UK in the Trafford
houses the single largest industrial
estate industrial estate in all of
Europe so our emissions profile
necessarily isn't very comparable to
other local authorities and I think
that's why we do need to make sure that
um
private sector Partners um are as
equipped as possible to drive forward um
carbon reduction measures um by
themselves and I think you know that's
an ongo ongoing body of work that um the
local authorities doing I'm sure you're
aware of the two studies that we've
commissioned in Trafford Park it's now
about transitioning into delivery phase
and I think that that's an exciting
prospect indeed so thank you very much
councel and thank you
chair okay thank you well um with that
um you can clearly see that there's a
lot of good news to uh report in that uh
in in that uh update um and even though
finances remain challenging for local
authorities across the across the
country including traford as we know
from our budget work that we're doing
you can see that you know the breadth of
what we do from housing to recycling to
Public Health to libraries to parks to
social care to many many other spaces um
we impact positively on people's lives
in traford every single day and it makes
me immensely proud to lead this burough
and also have the executive in place
that uh that helps with along with our
offices to deliver on that and first and
foremost our front line staff who are
out there every single day supporting
residents and and doing work on our
behalf so with that I hope the executive
are happy to not that
report wonderful so now we move on to
Urgent business of which there is none
so I will therefore draw this uh meeting
to a close at 20 7 consider that a
festive gift and um I wish everyone if I
don't see you um enjoy the F festivities
happy Christmas if you celebrate and all
the very best for the new year so thank
you